[Music]
with deep chain
we can easily perform molecular dynamic
simulations of protein complexes
to uncover links between structure
stability and function
to do this we need to input a pdb
structure file into deep chain
in this case we are going to use glute 5
as an example
we then move to the molecular dynamics
module load glute 5's design
and click on run simulation from native
structure
here we are given three parameters
the simulation time which is the
duration of the simulation in terms of
picoseconds
the equilibration time is a step prior
to the actual simulation
in which the molecules and surroundings
need to undergo a relaxation step
that here is expressed as a percentage
of the total time of the simulation
and the reference temperature of the
simulated environment in kelvins
in this example we are going to increase
the length of the simulation to 10
000 picoseconds equivalent to 10
nanoseconds
while leaving the equilibration time and
the temperature to their default values
after a few hours the results of the
simulation can be explored
including an interactive visualization
of the computed simulation
we can also download the simulation as a
video
but before that we are going to change
the representation from polymer cartoon
to coarse surface
[Music]
once that is done we can proceed to
download the simulation as an mp4 video
with just a few clicks deep chain
provides a simple yet effective
user-friendly interface
with world-class gpu super computing
infrastructure
that returns molecular dynamic
simulation results
in under 24 hours thank you for watching
for more information visit deepchain.bio
or contact us
at hello at deepchain.bio